- There are dumb questions.
There are questions that
waste your time and my time
and everybody else's time.
And I've never had a job in my
life that I was better than.
I was always just lucky to have a job.
Being able to create
an impulse within a consumer
to do something is an art form.
If you want to be Mark Zuckerberg,
the best you're ever going
to be is second place,
'cause Mark Zuckerberg will always be
a better Mark Zuckerberg than you.
- He's an American actor and investor.
He began his career as a model
and started acting as Michael Kelso
on the Fox sitcom, That '70s Show.
In 2004, he starred
in the psychological
film The Butterfly Effect
and gained even more attention.
He's Ashton Kutcher, and here's my take
on his top 10 rules for success.
Rule number 10 is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
And as always, if he says
something that really resonates with you,
make sure to put it in the
comments and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired, as well.
(loud whoosh)
(orchestral music)
- There are dumb questions.
There are questions that
waste your time and my time
and everybody else's time.
I started thinking, "Well,
what is a great question?
"What constitutes an
exceptional question?"
And I was thinking about it
and grinding on it and thinking about it,
and what I realized is
that a great question
is a question that's armed with knowledge,
that's armed with care and thought,
and that pierces into the gray matter
of the world and the
universe that we live in
and looks for problems and
inconsistency and broken things.
Great questions cause us
to sit for days and ponder a solution.
Great questions expose problems,
and problems are the seeds to solutions.
Great questions expose road blocks,
which are an entrepreneur's opportunity.
A great question sometimes
will arrive at a no,
which is the playground
for a rebel spirit.
And I have the great
opportunity in my life
to work with a lot of
unbelievable entrepreneurs
that are solving extraordinary problems,
and the one thing that
they all have in common
is they all ask extraordinary questions.
And they build their businesses
from these questions.
They build technology
from great questions,
questions that parse
apart existing businesses.
They tear them down.
They tear down conventions
that we just assume are true.
And they expose this
magical thing that exists
behind every great business, time,
that most magical resource in the world.
They find ways to save time.
I think time exists on two vectors.
It exists on one vector
which is longevity.
It's a vector that goes on and on and on,
and we're always in our lives
seeking longer lives, better lives.
It exists on another
vector, which is quality.
We want better lives,
lives that are more filled
with wonder and enjoyment
and entertainment.
Those are the two vectors of time,
and those are the two vectors
that every single business,
every single great business, exposes,
and they expose it
through great questions.
I think that if I could give
young Hollywood a suggestion,
it's to do something that I never did,
which is have the courage to stand up
and say what you believe
and be responsible for your actions now.
Learning from the bad things (mumbles)
A big part of growing up in this business,
which in a lot of ways I did,
was you spend a lot of time
just trying to be liked,
and you get really worried about,
"Do people like what I did?"
or, "Do people appreciate my work?"
because that is your paycheck.
And I think that having the guts
to just be yourself sometimes
is harder than people think.
I believe that opportunity
looks a lot like hard work.
When I was 13, I had my
first job with my dad,
carrying shingles up to the roof,
and then I got a job washing
dishes at a restaurant,
and then I got a job in
a grocery store deli,
and then I got a job in a factory,
sweeping Cheerio dust off the ground.
And I've never had a job in my
life that I was better than.
I was always just lucky to have a job,
and every job I had was a
stepping stone to my next job,
and I never quit my job
until I had my next job.
And so opportunities look a lot like work.
But I took this big risk and quit school.
I quit the one thing that was surefire
and went and became a model,
and got really bored really fast,
and didn't love being a coat hanger.
And then I became an actor,
which was like a coat hanger that talks,
and then I ultimately came
full loop and came back around,
and by the way, when you talk,
you're generally not even
speaking your own words.
You're speaking somebody else's words
and trying to make it sound really real.
And then I came full loop around
and started looking at technology again.
I started getting
interested in technology,
and started getting
interested in engineering,
and started really getting
interested in solving problems,
solving my own problems
and then solving other people's problems
and what the value of that is.
And so whether it's
technology or philanthropy or,
actually even performing
or being an actor,
I started to make it
about solving problems.
And I think that that's probably
the single biggest thing
that as an angel investor I
look for in entrepreneurs,
is people who genuinely want to solve
a problem, a real problem,
a problem that exists
not just for themselves,
but sometimes just for themselves
and then it turns into this wave effect
that solves other people's problems.
And sometimes by trying
to solve your own problem,
you're solving everybody else's problems.
'Cause generally, if you
want to affect the world,
you have to change yourself first.
Everybody tries to go
out and change the world
by changing other people and other things,
but the real way to do it
is by changing yourself,
and sometimes making those
really uncomfortable choices
to go up against everyone in
your life that you look up to
and take that risk to go be a model.
What is the most magnificent question?
Well, I have a question that I like to ask
to people that I admire in the world.
And when I run into someone
in the world that I admire,
and I get to run into these
people quite frequently,
I like to ask this one
question, and that is,
"What's the best advice
that you've ever received
"to get you to where you are?"
And I get amazing answers.
And I ask this question
in a very particular way.
I don't ask it when I'm in crisis.
I don't ask it when I need advice.
I ask it proactively,
because I sometimes think
that when you ask people that question of,
"What is the best advice?"
when you need advice,
you'll paint their answer
into your question.
And if you ask them while you're in crisis
and you expose your crisis to them,
they'll give you an answer
that is completely colored
by their own experience
and their own problem,
which isn't always the best thing to do.
The best thing to do is build up
this reservoir, this library,
of extraordinary advice
that you can access
anytime you're in crisis.
And that's what I do.
When I come up against a problem
or an obstacle or a road block,
I then go back to my index of advice
that I've received from
extraordinary people.
And I look at it.
And usually, the answer
is already in there.
So I thought last night,
as I was not taking this
opportunity for granted,
I decided to reach out to some folks
that I thought you guys might know
and ask them what the best piece of advice
they've received was so
that I could share it today.
So I reached out to my fiance, Mila,
and that was an easy one, right?
And she said, "Don't let your ego
"get in the way of asking for help."
To me that is great advice,
and to me, I can use
that advice all the time.
I reached out to Taylor Swift.
I figured she's at the top
of the charts right now.
I wonder if she would
actually even answer my email.
She did, which is amazing for the person
who's maybe the most busy
person on the planet right now.
She answered this email because
she thought it was important
that I share something with you.
And she said,
"Keep your hopes high and
your expectations low.
"You're not entitled to anything,
"but there's nothing that you can't earn."
I love that one.
You're not entitled to anything,
but there's nothing that you can't earn.
"And most importantly,
"enthusiasm can protect you
from absolutely anything."
Ooh, that's good.
When I watch her do interviews,
now I understand a little
bit more about her,
because she always has that
enthused up, that bubble going.
And I'm like, "You're
protecting yourself."
I dig it.
I like it.
So I reached out to Bradley Cooper.
He's got one of the number
one movies in America,
this American Sniper movie,
which I think is fantastic.
And he said, "Hey pal, thanks for asking.
"You know, often I thought about
"this old cartoon
commercial when I was a kid
"that sent a message to be yourself
"and just how vital that is to growth.
"And when I finally realized that notion
"some 30 years after
watching those commercials
"in between Saturday cartoons,
"I found a true difference
in my daily life.
"Knowing that we all have ourselves
"and all we have
ourselves, our uniqueness,
"that is what we can use to
cultivate in order to create
"or do whatever it is that
we want to do in this life."
Just be yourself.
Simple advice, but it's
really good advice,
and I can imagine that advice coming handy
in a moment of crisis.
So I reached out to Chris
Rock, and I love his.
"Advice.
"That's a hard one.
"How about, one, people that
can't listen can't lead.
"Two, one of the keys to success
"is the ability to listen people
"that you know that you are smarter than."
And I read that and I was like, "Oh, man.
"Oh no, the whole thesis
of my entire thing,"
which is there are no dumb questions,
but there are dumb questions,
maybe I just undermined myself
with that piece of advice.
And I do think that that's important.
I do think that it's
important to listen to people
that you know that you're smarter than,
'cause you may not be.
And then he signed it,
"The CEO of nothing,"
which I thought was pretty good.
And then I reached out to Eric Schmidt,
who's a friend of mine, and he said,
"Always return phone calls.
"Take the time.
"If you put good energy
out, it comes back.
"Whenever possible, say yes.
"Life is just who you travel with."
I thought that was pretty killer.
And this list goes on and on and on.
And what I found is, most
successful people always have
more than one piece of advice.
(audience laughs)
That's my question.
That's the question that I like to ask,
and that's the question
that leads me to solutions
and leads me to road blocks sometimes
and leads me to internal quandary,
which leads me to be a
better person, I think.
The sexiest thing in the entire world
(audience cheering)
is being really smart.
And being thoughtful, and being generous.
(audience cheering)
Everything else is crap, I promise you.
It's just crap that
people try to sell to you
to make you feel like
less, so don't buy it.
(audience cheering)
Be smart, be thoughtful, and be generous.
I like to sit down with founders
and I like to work on removing
friction from process,
whatever it might be,
and creating products that are intuitive.
And one of the things that I get
from working in the creative
space and being an actor
is really understanding
feeling and touch and art,
and it's an art.
Being able to create in impulse
within a consumer to do
something is an art form.
I can probably give you 10
or 20 examples of companies
that have really just taken
software that was archaic software
that was untouchable by consumers
and actually brought it
down to a consumer level.
That is becoming the process
to building a great
software company these days.
You can look at a company like Zenefits.
There's always been HR software
that's been out there in
some way, shape or form.
Or you can look at Robinhood,
and there's always been
ways that you can interface
and do stock exchanges.
But making it something that
the average consumer can
intuitively understand
and touch and play with and use
and have it be beneficial in their life
is about understanding the intuition
and the feeling of the consumer.
Generosity has to be at the core
of anything and everything we do.
Some of the best advice I ever received is
somebody once told me that
the difference between good
and bad is very simple.
Is it good for you, is it good for me,
and is it good for the greater good?
If it doesn't fall into those
three categories, it is bad.
Is it good for you, is it good for me,
and is it good for the greater good?
And if our actions are oriented
by actions of generosity
that are good for me and good for you
and good for the greater good,
we'll always be moving the boat forward,
the boat that we're all in.
I think generosity is paramount.
Steve Jobs said when you grow up,
you tend to get told that the
world is the way that it is,
and that your life is to live
your life inside the world
and try not to get in too much trouble,
and maybe get an education and get a job
and make some money and have a family.
But life can be a lot broader than that
when you realize one simple thing,
and that is that everything
around us that we call life
was made up by people that
are no smarter than you.
(audience cheering)
And you can build your own things.
You can build your own life
that other people can live in.
So build a life.
Don't live one, build one.
I see a lot of entrepreneurs that come in,
and they have a really great
idea to solve something.
And I start to talk to them.
I start to find out who they
are and what they're about.
And they sort of jump from the
problem that they're solving
to who they're going to be
or what they're going to get.
It's like I have this red flag
in my pocket that goes up,
and I'm like, "Wow.
"That guy wants to be Mark Zuckerberg.
"That guy wants to be Pinkus.
That guy wants to be Steve Jobs."
Or that guy just has got
this idea, and he's like,
"Yeah, and the market cap
is this and it's this,
"and we're going to make this much money
"and it's going to be a
billion dollar company."
And then I have this switch in my head
that just starts to shut off
really slowly when I hear this,
because they're jumping to the effect.
And if you want to be a real entrepreneur,
you have to be the cause.
You have to be the creator of
somebody else's new reality,
which eliminates time, space,
motion, pain, friction.
That's what engineering is.
It was the first thing
that I learned as an engineering student,
was scientists look at problems
and they find out about problems,
and engineers solve them.
And it's the one thing that
really, really stuck with me.
And those guys that want
to be Mark Zuckerberg,
or girls that want to be
the next big entrepreneur,
not the next big, but the
one that already exists,
if you want to be Mark Zuckerberg,
the best you're ever going
to be is second place,
'cause Mark Zuckerberg will always be
a better Mark Zuckerberg than you.
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
And if your chase is for
a billion dollar company,
you may not make a dollar.
So I wanted to tell this story
about a guy named Carl Fisher.
How many people here
know who Carl Fisher is?
A couple people.
It's interesting only a couple
people know who this guy is,
and after you hear this
story, you're going to wonder,
"Wow, how do I not know who this guy is?"
And when I heard this story...
Carl Fisher was one of
the greatest marketers
in American history.
As a young kid, Carl Fisher
couldn't see very well.
His eyesight was pretty poor,
and he would go to school
and he would sit in the front
of the class trying to see,
but he was still a poor student.
He didn't do well,
and the teacher moved him
to the back of the class.
So when he was a young kid, he quit school
because there was nothing
really there for him.
He couldn't even see the damn blackboard.
So he was like, "Fuck
it, I'm out of here."
He bails.
So then Carl gets this idea,
and he's going to sell candy on the train.
There was this candy boys,
and they walked down the
aisle with these boxes,
and they'd sell candy.
And so Carl gets this idea.
But Carl is no ordinary Carl.
Carl is an amazing marketer.
And so what he does is he gets a t-shirt,
and on the t-shirt he pins
this print of a naked lady.
(audience laughs)
And this shmock, smock, whatever
you call a Jewish smock.
It's shmock in Jewish.
It's Shabbat, so I can say shmock.
He has a shmock.
And he walks down the
aisle with his candy box,
and as he passes these
businessmen, he goes like this,
and keeps walking.
And they're like, "Hey,
kid, get back here."
(audience laughs)
Carl says, "Okay."
They would be like, "What's on that?
"What do you got underneath there?"
And he's like, "I'll show
you what's underneath there.
"Just buy some candy."
(audience laughs)
Phenomenal marketing tactic, right?
Like I'm going to show you
a little bit of the juice,
and then I'm going to shut it off,
and then once you buy this thing,
I'm going to give you the full product.
And so Carl makes a lot of money,
'cause these guys really
want to see naked pictures.
(audience laughs)
We all know that you want
women on your platform early,
hot ones first, and then everybody comes.
Carl knew this way back in the day.
So he makes a lot of money,
and then he gets this idea
he wants to sell bicycles.
So Carl Fisher, he sees
all these bicycles.
This is back in late 1800s.
He sees all these bicycles
in Europe, and he's thinking,
"This is going to explode
in the United States."
And so he opens up a bicycle shop.
And nobody comes.
Nobody is buying bicycles.
And so he goes and he gets this guy.
He puts a wire from one
building to the next building,
and he gets a guy that knows
how to tightrope on the bicycle.
And people come and they're
like, "Wow, this is amazing."
And he finds some guy that
can do a trick on a bicycle,
and people start coming
and buying bicycles.
And so he starts to sell
these bicycles and sell these bicycles.
And then the automobile starts to boom.
And he's like, "Wow, this is the future."
Now you got to remember,
Carl can't see so well,
but he gets a car with all
his money, and he loves it.
And he's driving this car, blind as a bat,
and he loves the speed of this thing,
and the agility and the
control that he has.
And so he opens up a car
shop, and he opened up
basically the first automotive
dealership in the world.
And so he starts selling these
cars and selling these cars
and making a lot of
money and a lot of money,
and sells his bike shop, obviously,
in order to do the down payment.
Takes this bigger risk with cars,
and of course, people start buying cars,
and it's the first automobile dealership
in the United States.
And then he starts thinking to himself.
He's seen all these people driving cars,
and he thinks, "Someday, these people
"are going to want to
drive these cars at night."
And so he invents the headlight.
And he sells the headlight,
and he makes a lot of money.
And so now he's a millionaire
back at the turn of the century,
and he's got all this money,
and he's doing extremely well for himself.
And he goes to, I think
he was in Minneapolis,
and he's trying to sell cars
and sell this headlight.
So he hooks this car
up to a hot air balloon
and he's flying over
the city in Minneapolis
and trying to sell these
cars and promote his brand,
promote what he has.
And he sees this girl
down in the crowd below,
young girl, beautiful girl.
And he says, "Land the balloon.
"I have to go meet this girl."
So he meets the girl, they fall in love.
And she's like, "You've worked so hard.
"You have all this money.
"Why do you keep working?
"What are you trying to do?"
And Carl is like, "I just see things."
He was blind, blind as a
bat, but he had vision.
And he was like, "I just see these things,
"and I have to make them happen."
And she's like, "Well, you should
"just really settle
down and have a family."
And he's like, "Yeah, but
this is what I want to do."
And he's like, "Well, I'm just
going to do one more thing,
"and then I'll stop."
And so he goes to Indianapolis,
and he has this idea that
these people love cars.
(mumbles) obsessed with cars.
He's like, "I think people
will want to race these cars.
"They're already racing them."
So he's going to make this track,
and people are going to race these cars.
So he invents the Indy 500.
He builds the Brickyard,
and people are like, "Carl, you're crazy.
"Nobody is going to watch
cars go around in a circle.
"This is insane."
(audience laughs)
And he says, "Not only
will they come and watch,
"they'll pay a dollar."
And so he starts to charge people,
and he invents the Indy 500.
He invents the Brickyard.
And the first race, like six
people die, because people--
(audience laughs)
Really funny.
That guy just died, guys.
Slow it down.
Too soon.
That's too soon?
Okay.
So anyway, like six people
die in the first race
'cause it's the brick and
people are flying off.
And so it was a huge disaster.
But then he stays at
it and he stays at it,
'cause even though he failed,
he knew that he could change it.
And he changed the surface,
and people start to come,
and it actually starts to grow,
and it builds into the Indy 500 as it is.
His wife is like, "Okay,
Carl. this is a debacle.
"Let's just stop doing these things.
"Let's go on vacation."
So he takes 'em on vacation.
This is around like 1910.
They go down to Florida, which
at the time was like this,
there was a couple little resorty areas,
but it was kind of a mosquito
infested environment.
But they're there and they're on vacation,
and he sees this bridge
going out into the distance,
and he's like, "What the hell is that?"
And the wife is like, "Carl, don't.
"Don't go.
(audience laughs)
"Just relax."
And he's like, "I just want to find out
"what's going on with this thing."
So he goes and he hunts down the guy,
and he finds out this
guy is trying to build
the largest bridge in the world.
And Carl is like, "Well,
what's on the other side?"
And the guy is like, "Well, nothing.
"It's just a swamp area.
"It's nothing."
(audience laughs)
And so Carl says, "Well,
take me over there."
So they go over, and he
starts looking around,
and he's surveying the
land, and he's looking.
He's like, "Wait a second."
And he sort of gets down
on his hands and knees,
and he's looking and
drawing a little thing.
And the guy is like, "What are you doing?"
He's like, "I think we
could backfill all this
"and turn it into a giant resort place."
And the guy is like,
"Well, if you want to
do it, you can do it.
"I'm not getting involved."
And he's like, "Well, yeah,
"but you want people to come
for your bridge, right?"
Because the guy couldn't
get money, he's like,
"I'll help you finish the bridge.
"I want the land on the other side."
And the guy is like, "Okay."
So he starts backfilling,
backfilling, backfilling,
builds it up, builds
up these giant casinos,
does this whole thing.
It's Miami Beach.
He's building Miami Beach.
Carl is otherwise known as
Mr. Miami because of this.
And he fills it in and he
builds all these casinos
and this huge area and this whole thing.
And nobody comes.
And he's got this giant
infrastructure now,
casinos and stores and
houses, and nobody comes.
And he's like, "Oh man,
I got to do something."
So he gets an elephant.
People in America hadn't seen an elephant.
But if there's an elephant,
people will come to see the elephant.
And he starts to tell people.
He goes to Congress and
petitions for a highway
from the north coming south,
and they build the Dixie Lane.
He had enough money at the time
where he could convince them
to build the Dixie Lane Highway
from all the way up north
all the way down to Miami.
And nobody comes.
And he's like, "This is a nightmare."
He's dumped everything he had,
all the money from the
headlight, into this thing,
and nobody comes.
And so he kidnaps the
president of the United States,
and he takes the president
of the United States
out into this place and gets
photographs of him there.
He's friends with him, so
he sort of kidnapped him.
It's a better story if he
actually kidnapped him,
but I made that part up.
(audience laughs)
So he takes the president
of the United States
and he takes pictures of
him out in this island,
and people start to
come, one by one by one,
and it's the biggest land
boom in American history.
And there are people who are literally
setting up card tables in
their front lawn, selling land,
and it's going, and it's going.
It's like the Internet right now.
It's just happening,
and everybody is coming,
and they're coming and they're coming,
and they're selling, and
the prices are going up,
and Carl is making millions.
He makes $100 million before 1920.
And then he gets a brilliant idea.
(audience laughs)
Montauk, Miami of the north.
And he dumps it all into Montauk.
Everything he's got goes into Montauk.
And he's building it up.
His wife is furious.
By the way, she adopted a baby
he didn't even know about.
That's a whole nightmare story.
Carl starts drinking a lot.
Builds up Montauk.
The stock market crashes.
He loses everything.
Completely wiped out.
Carl Fisher died in a trailer
home outside of Miami,
and about a week before he died,
somebody took him up in a blimp
and they took him over Miami,
and he was able to see what he had built.
But that's all he had.
He didn't have a dime.
He didn't have a penny.
Hardly anyone would remember his name.
But he gave that to all of those people.
And he knew that no one could
ever take that away from him.
He could never lose that.
He might not have been able to see,
but he had the vision to know
that it wasn't about his name
or somebody remembering him.
It wasn't about the billion dollars.
It was about uncovering
that which was concealed,
the swampland, the corners of the room,
the way people can exchange,
the way people can
connect with each other,
the way that a database can be built.
It's about uncovering.
It's about Airbnb changing
the hotel industry.
It's about disrupting markets boldly
in a way that you can leave that behind
for everybody else to have and share.
And Carl Fisher knew that.
So you might not remember his name,
but you use his product every day.
You might've visited his town.
And the only thing I can
impart upon young entrepreneurs
is it's not about being
like somebody else.
It's not about the billion dollars.
It's about how you can
affect other people's lives,
enrich them, improve them,
how you can eliminate
the space between people,
how you can eliminate pain and friction,
and how you can uncover that which one day
was just a big swampland.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Kevin Lopez asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know,
what did Ashton say that
really resonated with you?
What was the most
important take home point
that you took from this video?
Leave it in the comments.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Thank you again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
I'll see you soon.
(loud whoosh)
(phone ringing)
- Yeah.
- [Mike] Hey Steve, it's Mike.
- Hey.
- [Mike] Hey, I think I may
have found a project for you.
It's more of an R and D
outcast than anything,
but it's actually a project
you approved some time back.
Why don't you look into it?
- So this is the Macintosh team?
- Mm-hmm.
Jesus.
- No, it's just Steve.
- It's really good to see you, Steve.
- Bill (mumbles)
It's good to see they
got A players over here.
- Mm-hmm.
- Hi, Steve Jobs.
- What's your name?
- (mumbles) (clears throat) Burrell Smith.
- Burrell Smith.
- Oh, sorry for the mess.
We're just a bunch of degenerates, so.
- It's okay.
I like degenerates.
- Yeah.
- Who's your project lead?
- Uh, Jef Raskin.
I don't know where he is.
- Jef Raskin. (exhales)
Okay, I'll deal with him.
I'll be taking over now.
- Um, sorry, taking over, like
the entire Macintosh project?
- Yeah.
- Awesome.
- Where's your design team?
- Team?
- Show me your credibility.
- Well, obviously, ease of
use is a big feature here.
We're trying to develop
a simpler interface
that's geared towards
the real layman end user,
but we're kind of struggling
with the interface,
and to be frank, the results have been--
- Shit.
- Yeah.
- [Steve] What's it got under the hood?
- (mumbles) kick ass stuff.
64K RAM, 256 bitmap
display, Motorola 6809.
We're going to run the 68,000.
- But dude, that's Lisa's processor.
- That's correct, dude.
I don't care where the budget is.
Give me that processor.
- Done.
- Hey, Steve.
How are you, man?
(Steve laughs)
- Chris Espinosa.
- Yep.
- You're working on the Macintosh?
- Yeah.
- Good.
Then this is going to be fun.
Okay, let's go back to what
you were saying before.
This thing is for the everyman, right?
That's our end user.
It's the schoolteacher.
It's the garbage man.
It's the kid.
It's some grandma out in Nebraska.
So we need to make this thing simple.
It's got to work like,
like an appliance.
- Hey, Jef.
Steve Jobs is here.
Since you weren't around...
- Some of the project leads
were having a meeting with Motorola.
Why exactly are you here?
- I'm here to help build the Macintosh.
- I'm not sure that
that's practical for us.
We're actually trying
to avoid this project
becoming another over bloated disaster.
- Okay, Jef.
You got my attention.
- Look, Steve, you didn't
want to be involved
back when we started this
thing, and that was fine by me.
I just wanted you to cut the checks.
Be involved, just don't turn Macintosh
into a measure of revenge for you.
Everyone knows about your
fallout with Team Lisa,
so trust me when I say we're doing fine.
- Okay, Jef,
let's get a couple things straight.
We don't do fine.
And we don't accept things
the way that they are,
and we don't stop innovating.
Your machine lacks power,
and your little interface, it needs work.
And I'm here to help with that.
Now I'm not trying to take
Macintosh away from you.
I want you on this team,
but you can either get on board
or you can get the fuck out.
Okay, now we got a lot of work
to do, so let's get to it.
Bill, you come with me.
- Okay.
Where are we going?
- Recruiting.
- Shit.
- Do you know why people buy an Apple?
Why do they buy an Apple,
not the competitor?
Because it's got bravado.
It's social status.
No. You know what?
It's even more than that.
It's social currency.
We've raised the bar.
If we want to stay there,
we got to risk everything.
Great artists, Dylan, Picasso,
Newton, they risk failure,
and if we want to be great,
we got to risk it, too.
Everything is a pressing issue.
If we want to make the
vision for Lisa a reality,
we got to put in the hours
and make something great.
- Yeah, but we have a hard
date on this software,
and I'm sorry, but adding pretty fonts
is not going to change that.
Bill?
- If you don't share
our enthusiasm and care
for the vision of this company--
- No, no, no, no, no.
It's just, I'm not understanding--
- Get out.
- What?
- Get your shit and get out.
You're done.
- What, are you going to fire me?
- No!
I already fired you!
Why are you still here?
- Steve, he was our best
programmer in the division.
- He's the best programmer
that doesn't care about our vision.
(laughter)
(Red clears throat)
- Red, hey.
(laughter)
You're wondering why I'm
going through your stuff.
(laughter)
Okay.
That's, see,
I needed to borrow your saw
because I need to chop down a tree
(laughter)
because there's something stuck in it,
an animal, a rabbit.
(laughter)
There's a rabbit stuck in a tree,
and I want to return
that rabbit to the wild
so it can lay its eggs.
(laughter)
- Council, rabbits don't...
How the hell did a rabbit get up a tree?
(laughter)
- [Michael] Uh, Eric threw it up there.
- Eric threw a rabbit up a tree?
(laughter)
- Yeah.
He's a sadistic bastard.
(laughter)
You know he had a cow?
(peaceful music)
- Who changes these light bulbs?
It must be a nightmare.
- Adam.
- Oh, here.
You want the coat?
Are you cold?
- I can't do this.
Could you please take me back to work?
- No.
No, that's not the deal.
The deal is that we're
going to walk around
and we're going to look at
the twinkly lights and then--
- Why are you messing everything up?
- That's what people do.
They buy each other flowers
and they go to museums--
- You know me.
This stuff freaks me out.
It's fake.
What's wrong with what we're doing?
It's working.
We don't have to fight.
We don't have to--
- Maybe I want to fight.
- Yeah, well I don't.
- What are you going to do?
You're never going to feel anything?
How are you going to do that?
- I don't know.
I'll figure it out.
- You're so messed up.
- Yeah?
I don't need you to take care of me.
I take care of myself.
That's what I do.
Why don't you go find some other girl
who's not going to hurt you?
- Because I love you.
- It's obvious.
I completely love you.
There.
You're such a wimp.
- [Emma] I am not a wimp.
- Well then be with me.
- Okay, you're going to fight me.
Is that the way you're going to fight?
You can't fight me.
You're miniature.
You're like a girl Rick Moranis.
You fight like a hamster.
- Hey, hey.
Excuse me, excuse me.
You can't do that here.
- [Emma] Okay.
I'm sorry.
(acoustic guitar music)
(Emma grunts)
- All right, you're out.
- I can't keep doing this.
♫ Put your hands in the water
I'm not going to see you again.
♫ Watch them go under
- I know.
That makes sense.
♫ Put your hands to the light
♫ Watch the light
- Bye.
♫ Come through
♫ And I will let you go